bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à 57 ans après le discours de
martin luther king et l'historique aveux
de jouer mais ils étaient plusieurs
dizaines de milliers à manifester contre
le racisme systémique et les violences
policières dans les rues de washington
hier alors que cette colère est toujours
aussi présente aux états unis est ce que
le mouvement blake lively amateur peut
jouer un rôle dans l'élection
présidentielle selon vous au milieu
incontestablement les questions de
racisme et de violences policières vont
être au centre de la campagne électorale
ces violences policières elles sont
réelles puisque on sait qu'il ya environ
1000 personnes qui sont tuées chaque
année par léa par les policiers ce qui
est si on compare la france par exemple
à population égale c'est à peu près
quinze fois plus donc c'est très
important
c'est une question de racisme mais c'est
aussi une question de violence car si
les afro américains sont tués à peu près
25% des victimes sont afro américaine
alors que les afro américains en passant
à peu près de 12% de la population cela
dit beaucoup de blancs sont également
tués par la police dont qui a à la fois
un problème de racisme est un problème
de violence et on assiste là à une joute
entre les deux camps le camp démocrate
mettant en avant ces violences
policières et le trump et les
conservateurs mettent en cause les
actions et berry démocrate vis à vis des
manifestants et plus exactement leur
inaction supposée à l'encontre des
manifestants violents et donc je pose
comme le candidat de la loi et de l'or
alors justement donald trump se pose
donc comme le président le candidat de
la loi et de l'ordre face à un mouvement
dont il qualifie les militants de voyous
et d'anarchistes est ce que c'est une
stratégie qui peut lui coûter sa
réélection à donald trump ce difficile à
dire à l'heure actuelle parce que ce
mouvement black l'animateur et ce
mouvement contre le racisme et quand
même solidement enracinée aux états unis
en quelque sorte depuis les émeutes de
ferguson en 2015
il y à une sensibilisation à cette
question de du racisme et des violences
policières
maintenant le fait que les
manifestations soient violente tout
aussi poussé vers les urnes des
électeurs de classe moyenne qui qui
s'inquiètent de ces désordres et
d'ailleurs certains d'entre eux
présentent ces manifestations comme une
attaque sur les classes moyennes
donc d'un côté les démocrates ont
intérêt à mobiliser le vote des noirs
les noirs très majoritairement démocrate
la question c'est qui se déplacent pour
aller voter parce qu'ils s'abstiennent
aussi beaucoup habituellement et donc
qui récupérera le plus grand nombre de
voix dans cette joute s'est un petit peu
difficile de le dire à l'heure actuelle
alors à kenosha deux manifestants ont
été tués par balle un autre gravement
blessé à part un adolescent de 17 ans
qui avaient répondu à l'appel à former
des milices pour contrer les
manifestants antiracistes la stratégie
de tension au choisi par donald trump à
ce qu'elles ne risquent pas d'aggraver
les divisions qui secoue la société
américaine ainsi tout à fait le les
républicains la convention républicaine
qui s'est tenu la semaine dernière à
prix très clairement position pour les
citoyens miliciens qui vont défendre
leur quartier des armes à la main contre
le contre les manifestants et on a vu
l'intervention d'un couple un le couple
mccluskey
pti avait défendu son quartier avec lui
un fusil d'assaut et et un pistolet et
lorsque les images de ce couple avait
fait le tour bpt
internet et ils ont été invités à la
tribune à la convention nationale
républicaine et ils ont dû y regarder
c'est nous qui sont mises en cause
alors que nous faisons que défendre le
quartier et et lutter contre les
désordres alors que les manifestants
peuvent détruire et piller en toute
impunité
l'ensemble des ligues de sport
américaine la nba en tête ont refusé de
jouer jeudi et vendredi en réaction à
l'arrestation de jacob black cat 1 on le
rappelle de cette balle dans le dos à
part un policier blanc cette initiative
historique du monde de sportifs a été
saluée par barack obama mais rapidement
condamnés par donald trump qui qualifie
la nba est d'organisation devenu
politique
à quel impact peut avoir ce genre
d'initiative sur l'élection
présidentielle est sûre plus
généralement la politique américaine
le tournoi la nba et est extrêmement
populaire donc il est évident que les
sportifs d'une manière générale sont
extrêmement populaires donc le le fait
de prendre position dans une polémique
comme celle là est effectivement très
important il ya une autre chose qui est
intéressante c'est que ce tournoi de
hand billets doit va pouvoir reprendre
et ce qui a été négocié c'est que les
gymnases pourront accueillir des bureaux
de vote
et c'est une des grandes questions
l'accès au vote
on le voit avec toute cette polémique
sur le vote par correspondance ou encore
une fois le le grand enjeu pour les
démocrates c'est d'arriver à faire que
les afro américains à y voter et donc
s'il ya plus de bureaux de vote ouverts
ce sera plus facile pour eux d'aller
voter et c c'est donc ce qui a été
négocié entre la nuit et les autorités
ça sera le mois de la fin didier combo
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste des
états unis et auteur de l'ouvragé être
américains aujourd'hui
enjeux d'une élection présidentielle
publiés aux éditions gallimard